texas governor greg abbott uh governor
did i rightly
describe the bill in your state and am i
rightly describing
the restrictive voting laws in delaware
sean i've heard this topic discussed at
length over the past few days
no one articulated it better than you
just did
you provided the best summary you get a
10 out of 10
on your entire monologue i would however
add one thing to what you said
because you're talking about what biden
has been saying
and biden is calling people names and
you left one out
you left out the fact that biden called
me a neanderthal
for opening at texas 100 and eliminating
mass so now i am
by biden's assessment a neanderthal
and a racist both of which are
completely wrong
what's going on in texas with regard to
this election law we're trying to pass
as you pointed out very perfectly
we are adding hours to vote not
subtracting hours to vote
everything we're doing is perfectly
legal the only other thing i would add
is the hypocrisy of the democrats from
texas as well as in washington d.c
because
one thing the democrats from texas are
trying to achieve in washington d.c
they are trying to get the united states
senate to drop their filibuster rule
well think about this what the texas
democrats are doing
they are filibustering in texas to try
to get the washington d.c democrats
to stop the filibuster rule that is the
height of hypocrisy
all they want to do is complain they
want to spread false information
about what the law really does i can
guarantee you
based upon what you said in your
monologue as well as what the facts are
there is zero chance that the texas law
when it does get passed
will be overturned by a court of law
because what we are doing
is perfectly constitutional talk about
the the coverage of people saying that
you might have
these democrats arrested when they land
back in texas
arrested for what under what statute
so what the law is by constitution the
house sets the rules about what happens
when a quorum is broken and what happens
is this
and that is once a call on the house has
been made which it has been
then the sergeant-at-arms for the texas
house of representatives
can work with the texas department of
public safety to go
arrest apprehend whatever word you want
to choose and bring to the capitol
the missing house members who are
responsible for breaking a quorum
the only limitation to that sean is that
the jurisdictional limits to that
are in the state of texas which is why
the texas law enforcement is not
not up there in washington dc or some
other location trying to pursue these
house members
so here's the deal as long as those
texas house members remain in washington
d.c we're not going to have a quorum
but know this a special session in texas
last 30 days once this 30-day special
session expires
if the members return i'll call another
one
and we will be back in session unless
they leave again in which case
i will continue calling special session
after special session
after special session so they will have
to be gone from the state of texas all
the way up until the next election
here's the bottom line because this is
maybe they could pay this is the point
go ahead sir this is the point the
democrats have not thought of
what is their endgame they haven't
thought about that and i can tell you
what the endgame is
we are going to have a special session
where these and other issues are going
to be better on including
doing a better job of securing our
border including
cutting our property taxes in texas
including helping our teachers
our retired teachers that were they were
voted uh
relief today by the texas senate but
they're not going to get it
because the texas house members are not
there we voted out of the texas senate
today property tax relief
that the people of texas will not get
because the democrats
were not in the texas house of
representatives
so they have a job to do and let me tell
you something texas voters
are going to be extremely angry at the
texas house members for not showing up
and not doing the job if you didn't show
up and do your job if
other people who are watching your show
right now did not show up and do their
job
they would be losing their job or losing
their pay that is exactly
what is going to happen to the members
of the texas house of representatives
but in other words it's not an arrest in
the in the traditional sense but the
texas law allows for law enforcement to
escort them to do their job which is
mandated by law is that a is that a
correct statement
that and i'll add to it so they will be
brought to the capitol
they will be brought to the texas uh
house
chamber and the house chamber doors will
be locked
and no one can leave without permission
of the speaker of the house
last question i am concerned about the
weaponization
of the department of justice as the new
attorney general merrick garland now is
going after
georgia that has far more accessibility
for voting
than joe state of delaware that seems to
me
like they have weaponized our justice
department
and why wouldn't they go after the state
with the most restrictive laws like joe
state because he never lifted a finger
to to lift the the restrictions in
delaware
exactly it's completely hypocritical
also
as you were pointing out texas has more
uh
voting hours in early voting then does
delaware the same is true
in texas versus the state of new york
for example but of course there's no
chance
uh that the administration would go
after delaware or new york or
any democrat state so the american
people are getting a
feel for where the bite administration
is and that is hostile to anything
that doesn't fit the socialistic agenda
of the biden administration
governor abbott thank you for being with
us we appreciate the update tonight hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else